io amo i videogiochi da quando memoria
sono cresciuto con i videogiochi e si
sono stati parte importantissima della
mia vita
potrei anche dire non sono esagerato che
in parte l'hanno salvata perché all'età
di 8 anni viene diagnosticata una brutta
malattia ormonale
al di là dei problemi fisici medici che
essermi causa
portò me stesso verso un isolamento
sociale
questo sono io sostanzialmente in
pochissimo tempo a cui si
quasi 100 kg arrivai a pesare 96 chili
per un metro e cinquanta di altezza
totale blocco dello sviluppo questo fu
molto pesante in un periodo quale quello
dell'adolescenza già di per sé
particolare e mi portò verso un
progressivo isolamento sociale cosa
accade che i videogiochi rimasero il mio
migliore nonché unico amico e io mi ci
rifugiai spendendo tantissimo e
tantissime ore per tanti anni della mia
vita
però non voglio ovviamente parlarvi solo
dell'aspetto triste ma per me è stata
un'esperienza comunque positiva perché
ho potuto giocare giocando potuto
imparare
i videogiochi hanno influenzato
realmente la mia vita giocando prodotti
come se volesse se ho imparato la storia
mi sono avvicinato alla passione per
l'antichità e questo ha influenzato la
mia vita reale ho studiato liceo
classico poco studiate archeologia
che cosa ho fatto dall'età di 10 anni
guido delle macchine velocissime
costosissime e ho fatto dei calcoli
probabilmente ho guidato anzi
sicuramente ho guidato più nella vita
virtuale che in quella reale che cosa ha
fatto anche nei videogiochi ho avuto un
grande vantaggio ho potuto salvare
centinaia e centinaia di principesse in
qualità di un eroe altissimo slanciato
ricevendo come ricompensa dei caldi baci
da queste principesse
ovviamente non sono in questo non è solo
la mia vita ma milioni di persone stanno
crescere o sono già cresciute insieme ai
videogiochi compiendo delle avventure
straordinarie che furono precluse alle
generazioni precedenti ovviamente voi
non dovete pensare che io sia l'unico
una persona sociale che è cresciuta al
chiuso della propria cameretta lo
stereotipo del nerd che videogioca come
tutti noi immaginiamo coloro che
videogiocano ormai i videogiochi sono
una cosa per tutti il 90 per cento dei
ragazzi in età scolare attualmente sta
utilizzando i videogiochi
il 44 per cento delle donne utilizza e
videogiochi quindi andiamo a sfatare
questo luogo comune del videogioco
luogo per soli uomini
un altro dato molto interessante il
filone maggiormente in crescita
attualmente quindi segmento di mercato
maggiormente in crescita nei videogiochi
è composto dalle donne over 50 tra il
2012 e il 2013 sono cresciute del 32 per
cento
ovviamente queste donne non giocano su
console ma utilizzeranno i telefonini
gli smartphone online facebook sono
passati 30 anni da quella prima foto qui
fece vedere durante una comunione che
tra l'altro è l'unica foto che esiste di
me tra gli 8 e 20 anni le cancellate
tutte le strappa i to the perché ancora
oggi ovviamente quel problema a portare
gli strascichi quando sono davanti
quando passò dinanzi a uno specchio
chiudo istintivamente gli occhi però
quello che ho avuto la fortuna di fare
trasformare quella che era stata la mia
più grande passione nel mio lavoro in
questi 30 anni ho lavorato con alcune
delle più grandi aziende al mondo dei
videogiochi elettronica ars vivendi nam
collaborato a tetris apa manna fifa sims
e quello che ancora oggi mi sorprende è
la grandissima capacità che videogioco
hanno avuto di evolversi in soli 40 anni
sono diventati l'industria principale
dell'intrattenimento
fatturano quasi 100 miliardi di dollari
in un solo anno molto più della musica
molto più del cinema molto più
dell'editoria ma più dei numeri quello
che ancora oggi mi ammalia in parte ne
sono ancora soggiogato e la
straordinaria capacità che videogiochi
hanno di generare emozioni
guardiamo questa foto ma è una casa
potete prendere migliaia nell'atto di
videogiocare noi prova delle emozioni
vedete i loro volti emozioni che possono
essere le più diversificate cooperazione
e competizione gioia paura frustrazione
rabbia e tutto questo non è causale
persone come me coloro che disegnano la
sceneggiatura dei videogiochi cosiddetti
game designer volutamente creano queste
continue tensioni emotive allo scopo di
tenere incollate le persone allo schermo
e questo è un modo per poi per guidare i
comportamenti delle persone non solo
all'interno dei videogiochi ma anche
all'esterno vi faccio un esempio di un
aneddoto parlando con il creatore di un
altro gioco in gioco che era stato molto
famoso a cavallo del 2010 su facebook il
gioco di nome pezzo site tra l'altro
questo ragazzo poi è diventato
ricchissimo perché ha venduto la sua
società una società alla società
americana che io lavoravo per 400
milioni di dollari fatto questo inciso
che cosa è successo durante le festività
natalizie le persone iniziarono a
comprare degli addobbi natalizi virtuali
da per abbellire le proprie case
virtuali
ora già questo mi sembrerebbe un segnale
di un mondo che il mondo che sta
impazzendo di un mondo totalmente fuori
controllo cioè persone che tirano fuori
dei soldi reali per comprare
abbellimenti virtuali ma perché
succedeva tutto questo andando a parlare
con i giocatori facendo delle indagini
mercato che cosa emerso le persone che
dicevano io ho quasi smesso di comprare
gli addobbi natalizi nella mia casa
reale perché nella mia casa reale le
avrebbero viste solo dieci venti trenta
persone l'alt ristretta cerchia di amici
che durante le festività in tre a casa
mia se io invece spendo qualche euro
nella mia casa virtuale questa casa sarà
vista da centinaia migliaia decine di
migliaia di persone perché c'è molta più
probabilità di essere vista e quindi ha
molto più senso che io spendere questi
soldi quindi questo è il potere anche
manipolatorio a volte che i videogiochi
possono avere ora vi riporto tre casi
per chiudere di come i videogiochi
possono essere anche una cosa
terribilmente seria non solo
utilizzabile per divertire e
intrattenere le persone ma anche per
aggredire e risolvere problemi reali voi
penserete che sia uno scherzo ma in
realtà uno dei prossimi premi nobel per
la medicina potrebbe essere un giocatore
che cosa sta succedendo senza che molti
di noi lo sanno
l'università di washington ha creato una
piattaforma online chiamata foldit
quotidianamente centinaia di migliaia di
persone provano a sintetizzare delle
proteine all'interno di un interfaccia
che assomigliano una sorta di tetris 3d
e stanno contribuendo realmente a
risolvere dei problemi legati a malattie
come le bolla come l'aids
laddove gli scienziati laddove i
supercalcolatori stanno fallendo il
potere collettivo delle persone che
mettono a disposizione il proprio tempo
e le proprie risorse mentali la
collaborazione sta ottenendo i risultati
incredibili attualmente la giocatrice
che al vertice della classifica di
foldit è una persona normalissima senza
una laurea è stata intervistata di
giorno fa la segretaria un lavoro
noiosissimo ma poi quando ritorna a casa
indossa i panni del supereroe e sta
realmente risolvendo dei problemi ancora
in ambito urbano si parla tanto di come
provare ad aggredire i tanti problemi
della città del futuro problemi legati
alla sostenibilità i videogiochi fanno
una cosa noi lo sapevamo ma
semplicemente sperimentando nella
creazione di giochi ora sono arrivati
degli studi scientifici anche
dall'università di stanford che cosa ci
dicono che quando una persona è
rappresentata mediante un avatar oppure
quando una persona guarda il mondo
attraverso una soggettiva in prima
persona e molti dei videogiochi ormai
sono in prima persona
otteniamo degli effetti fisici reali
ovvero aumenta la conducibilità
elettrica della pelle aumenti del
battito cardiaco quando questo si va
creando quando questa istanza si crea
noi ci leghiamo un oggetto al nostro
avatar al nostro gioco e quindi ci
rimaniamo attaccati come sta sfruttando
tutto questo la città di bristol in
inghilterra ha praticamente reso animati
animate tutte le componenti della città
le panchine e lampioni gli alberi ognuno
di essi ha un nome tu puoi scrivere dei
messaggi e questi oggetti ti rispondono
ti rispondono realmente quindi tu crei
un attaccamento con l'oggetto e qual è
il risultato poi concreto il risultato
concreto che ci sono meno atti di
vandalismo e le persone spontaneamente
si prendono iniziano a prendersi cura
degli oggetti perché ci hanno attaccato
un ricordo le sentono loro
l'ultima per chiudere un prodotto a cui
sto lavorando il tema è quello della
malattia mentale ci siamo detti un tema
difficile nessuno ne vuole sentire
parlare
le a slow falliscono nell'andare
nell'appoggiare frontalmente i ragazzi
provando a spiegare loro cosa sia la
malattia mentale che cosa stiamo facendo
un gioco che tratta questo tema in
questo gioco arriverà a centinaia di
migliaia di persone milioni di persone
stiamo raccontando all'interno del gioco
delle storie vere all'interno di luoghi
veri le istituzioni manicomiali
ora il video per conclude l'audio
by one way
le scene del ris topi che fa notare
questo il commento di alcune persone
senza armi il gioco
noi vogliamo suscitare emozioni così lo
si ricordi delle esperienze ma nel
mondiale perché è come dire
niente
la norma si occupava dopo è
la copriva l'abbracciava da accarezzava
era molto affettuoso a
lasciarla kill accadeva nulla di male io
mi scoprivano un capi all'inizio mi
faceva quasi paura temevo che mi volesse
fare del male e aspettavo sempre amore
perché io non meritano di vivere ma
meritano di essere ma dal cuore quindi
concludo dicendo giocate giocate giocate